[Musique]
cyrille melchior président du
département et bachil valy maire de
l'entre-deux signent le pacte de
solidarité territoriale le département
s'engage à soutenir à hauteur de 2,2
millions d'euros les projets
d'investissements et de 175000 euros les
projets sociaux de la commune est un
trésor pour la commune de l'entrevue et
bien sûr de la confiance qui nous est
accordée parce que il faut le dire quand
on présente des dossiers au département
nous avons
via sinon merci pour ton avec votre
accueil le financement du pst permettra
sur cette commune
la préservation du foncier la
réhabilitation des chemins d'accès et
l'aménagement des voiries
le pst arrive je dirais un moment
opportun pour la collectivité de l'antre
2 parce que nous avons eu des événements
climatiques birgitta et fac lire et donc
à partir de là nous avons utilisé les
fonds propres de la collectivité pour
enclencher sécurisé et bien sûr
certains chantiers auxquels les
habitations ont été inondées
les fonds alloués pour le fonctionnement
valoriseront les patrimoine culturel et
naturel de cette commune rurale et
financeront également des actions
sociales comme le portage de repas à
domicile pour les personnes âgées
le pacte de solidarité territoriale qui
a été mise en place par le département
accompagne cela accompagne cette
authenticité parce que le maire et son
équipe font des choix de préserver leur
patrimoine de l'entretenir d'améliorer
aussi les conditions de vie les routes
de mettre en place des actions sociales
pour les g onexone donc le département
accompagne cette ruralité
cette authenticité réunionnais
[Musique]